this is a production of Cornell
University
so I'm just going to do go through a
little bit this is the the structure
i'll give you a little bit of background
talk about farm escape ecology the two
way what is what if farms provide for
nature witness nature provide for farms
connecting people to the ecology of
their landscape understanding the people
side and then very briefly outline a
study that we're thinking of trying to
do so this is who we are I'm sorry this
is because everybody's this is I guess a
bit low for people but this is a we work
at Hawthorne Valley Farm which is in
Columbia County which is the New York
County which is on basically the border
with Massachusetts and it's a biodynamic
farm about two hours north of New York
City this is our regular staff you know
here's the here's the center of
operations and then the rest of us kind
of come along for the ride but just to
give you a little bit idea who we are so
that you can understand what we can or
can't do my wife is a botanist to plant
ecologist ana is actually an
anthropologist so she works with us with
the people part of things Kyle who's
here but in the insect collection today
is our technician but he's been working
a lot with ants and the patterns in the
landscape our son is the really into
dragonflies so he's a lot faster it has
a lot better eyes than I do our dog is
always with us and then I tend to
shuffle papers but if I can which makes
me more happy I'm actually a wildlife
ecologist as Emily said so just a little
bit of background Hawthorne Valley Farm
I'm not going to go into a whole lot of
detail about what biodynamic farming is
partially because I'm not all that
experienced in it but in terms of why
it's relevant or works with us a form of
organic farming that views the farm as
an individuality closely tied to its
social and ecological surroundings and
ideally largely self-sufficient in terms
of its nutrient flows so it is part of
that philosophy is what I'd say
ecological and so we fit into that they
tend to be diverse they tend to connect
with the community so the work a lot of
our work is connecting with the
community the people in the area which
fits into this philosophy so what we do
as a program farm scape ecology program
is try to encourage informed compassion
for our local working landscape its
people and other life and we work with
research and we work with outreach to
try to do that and it's really trying to
get enthusiasm trying to help people be
curious about their landscape and help
inform them at the same time we do try
to do original research but we're not in
an academic setting so our audience is
not really our scientific peers but it's
the people in the county the farmers we
interact with the general public so that
affects you know how we do our work for
better or worse so getting them to the
heart of what we try to do farm escape
ecology I think we try to think about it
in two ways we try to think about what
can farming potentially provide to
nature conservation in our landscape I'm
not talking I don't know the global
situation and then also the reverse what
can farm what can nature potentially do
for farming so it makes sense so you
tend to have look at there's a tendency
to look at a landscape like this either
as being production a pasture the
gardens of pasture etcetera or from the
perspective of nature conservation but
of course it's really a combined
landscape and that's what we try to
emphasize both in our research and as we
interact with people how does that all
go together one of the things that we've
found helpful in trying to communicate
with farmers and other people about what
can farming provide to nature is an idea
that builds on this and so this is what
Hawthorne value could be anyplace really
look like say 14 year 1400 you lots of
forests there might have been some
native agriculture there were probably a
lot more beaver this hillside probably
burned grip yeah not every year but
regularly may have looked something like
that and you had certain organisms
existing in that land
and then that landscape evolved over
time and you had this is maybe what look
like in 1870 same landscape this is the
same section but based on aerial
photographs and other historical
evidence this is sort of what it looked
like it its most open state and then
today and that would be what the
landscape looks like and then today I'm
jumping ahead you had various organisms
existing in there and then today it
looks more like this and so the question
becomes this is today's landscape you
got more roads Forest has come back you
have still have some fields and our
question is okay those native organisms
that existed in this landscape or
perhaps in this landscape where do they
find space in today's landscape and the
way that we try to think of that are
through analogies now I imagine this is
probably actually a simile but i'll say
technology but any we try to think of it
ecological analogies and what we mean by
an ecological analogy is it refers to a
human-shaped habitat which well not the
ones that the given organism co-evolved
with offer enough similarities or
analogies to be ecologically functional
for that species so an example is you
know this is what it looked this is what
a forest looks like after his burn you
have the shrub this brush coming up well
this is a lightly grazed pasture that
also has a lot of brush in it it's not
the same thing and I'm not trying to
claim it is but there are certain
species that occurred here for which
this analogy works this is another
example this is a beaver pond and this
is a cow pond again they're not the same
thing and there's certainly things in
here that are not in here but for
example some of the dragonflies that
like these edges that are like that
they'll be there and they'll be here so
we say this works as an analogy just for
that those species of dragonflies for
this and so dads come back to that
question where do they find a home they
answer as well where they find workable
and
and so what our challenge is you know
how can farming encourage such analogies
does that make sense so a lot of what we
do is try to work with farmers to help
them understand the history and the
ecology of their landscape from the
perspective of understanding those that
story and those analogies and this is
just this is some work we did for
Roxbury farm how many of you know
Roxbury farm I think you could be at a
seminar today where you actually hear
Jean Paul from Roxbury talking but if
you came here you're not going to hear
but we do ecological maps and then we
try to think of each of these habitats
and we try to imagine you know what
could they what might be analogies be
and how could those be encouraged this
is the same as a big farm this another
map this is Hawthorne Valley the same
idea a habitat map for a farm and then
don't worry about the small print but
this is the type of information that we
would give them we have that habitat map
and then for each of that hat those
habitats we talked about location nature
conservation value how it might interact
with agricultural production and
suggestions for management but we're not
prescriptive I mean the farmers know a
lot better than we know how that land
should be farmed so these are just ideas
it's just sore we're sharing our ideas
for a better or worse is this camera on
because I keep feeling I must be getting
my ear filmed or something as I'm
standing don't worry about okay so I'm
just going to run through some of these
habitats so that you get a little bit of
an idea of how we're thinking about this
so mature hay fields were the ecological
analogies who are the species of
conservation interest well for some
species the analogy might be between
prairies and hay fields now this works
as a structural analogy for these
grassland nesting birds I mean I think
they're fairly that's a fairly common
example that's brought up and in our
county now this is this is the
trajectory of open area in our county so
those those birds have certainly gone
through a real decline in inhabitat
availability since the 1880s but there
was not all that much
but one of the things that you bring
into the question when you're thinking
about those specific what makes that
work as a habitat for grassland birds is
well when does hanging happened relative
to when the young birds get out of the
nest so if you're hating it before the
birds are out of the nest then it
doesn't work as an analogy that makes
sense and this is just at some
historical work we did looking at date
of haying today that's the black space
behind this versus various historical
data we have from the county and the
point is paying is occurring much is
occurring earlier in general than it
occurred historically which makes that
analogy less viable for some of the
grassland birds because they fledge sort
of in here so if most of the hanging for
example the Shakers we're doing most of
their hang after the middle of june
beginning of july wires today a lot of
it's happening before that and that
makes it more difficult for those birds
to get there they're young off it
doesn't work and this is important when
you think about analogies it's not it's
you're not reconstructing Prairie it
that analogy doesn't work for
butterflies and the reason it doesn't
work for butterflies is there much more
botanically picky the caterpillar is a
butterfly's need to find like a monarch
you know goes out after the milkweed
they have to find the particular plants
they're looking for which aren't going
to be in a hay field so it doesn't work
that same analogy doesn't work so well
for butterflies old fields and poor
Meadows this is another habitat you find
on farms maybe the analogy is we do have
grasslands in our area that are hilltop
rocky grasslands some native grasses up
here there are organisms historically
that survived there may be some of those
actually come down into these old fields
and this is some work that my wife did
looking at the Botanical diversity of
pastures hay fields intensive pastures
dryer Hill pastures showing that you
know a great purport there are more
species in these dry health hillsides
plus more of them are
native so as a sort of a place where
you're going to have conservation of
native plant species these dry hillsides
are quite interesting in part perhaps
because there were sources in the
landscape that had species already
adapted those kinds of environments and
the great thing is it does work I like
butterflies so you got to bear with me
it does work for these butterflies
because you do have those native plants
there they're caterpillars can feed on
them so the analogy works for them
shrubby fields I talked and this this
slide should still be familiar this is
the one with the burn over and the post
cow shrubland that's one of the
analogies you might have who do you find
there well how many of you know the
eastern caught that sorry the New
England Cottontail have you heard about
that a New England Cottontail is
actually being considered for endangered
species status it's Silva lagus so it's
the same species as the eastern
cottontail but it's one that has
essentially used to be the only con tail
east of the Hudson shrubland species
it's declined dramatically and one of
the areas is are these shrublands so
that's one of the species you could put
potentially find in such an area
shrubland birds are also important that
many of them have been declining
dramatically so I'm just giving you a
quick kind of rundown don't worry about
the details but just giving you a little
bit of an overview for what some of
these different habitats might offer
potentially can offer one of the other
habitats that we've been looking at is
the old farm woodlot and its role as
being actually ancient farm as ancient
forest and when I talk about ancient I
mean force that has long been in forest
although extensive logging or other uses
may have occurred so the idea is a
primary forest is obviously one that
sort of basically never been almost
never been touched right whereas an
ancient force the idea is it's been in
forest for a long time although many of
those trees may not be particularly old
that makes sense so primary forest is
ancient but not all ancient forests are
primary and the interesting thing when
you look at the history of the landscape
so this is the 1940s that's the earliest
aerial photographs we have for our
region you see lots of farmland but you
see some of these areas that were left
in forest partially because they're
rocky but partially because all four
arms needed a woodlot for building barns
for wood or that sort of thing now today
yeah it just all looks like the same
thing however for us like this have some
special things because they were never
taken out of four as well you know never
in the past 10,000 years this is just an
example we were working in a farmland
setting this is another habitat map and
these dark areas here are plots that
we've realized were probably some of
these ancient forests one of the ways we
did that we were doing soil samples and
so we were looking at the depth of the
organic layer because when you plow
something that gets all mixed up and you
can't you don't have that deep organic
layer so we can use soils to help us
find which areas are ancient forest and
when you go into an ancient forest like
this you find a variety of old trees old
treo shrubs it's now none of these are
particularly big trees because logging
has occurred but the soil conditions are
such that you get something like
rattlesnake plantain does anybody know
rattlesnake plantain here great part
I think that sounds right my wife's to
the botanist so I'll take your word for
it but that could well be that's it's an
orchid we almost never sought and then
also we were walking through these old
farms these ancient forest plots and
there it was so there's some special
things going on in there we did some
studies with floodplain foresees to the
forests along creeks and we looked at
ancient versus not ancient forests and
what you find we categorize those
forests into different forest types and
then in this case we were comparing
cover by invasive shrubs and we found
that you know indeed the more recent for
us not surprising are the ones that had
the highest amount of invasive shrubs in
them whereas the older ones they hadn't
one of the interesting things to think
about is you picture you nice a shrub
when I say floodplain forest can you
picture this it's the areas along the
streams that regularly maybe once or
twice a year get flooded they're really
disturbed areas and if all that forest
is taken off then you have this great
inoculation of invasive species coming
down the creek and going in and being
able to set up there so if in the past
50 years you cleaned it up completely
then you have this big inoculation if
that's been in forest then those those
invasive species are much less able to
establish themselves and basically you
also see a higher diversity of native
species I won't go into that you have
meadows and ponds so that was a wet
meadow on a farm this is a farm pond
analogy as we mentioned before might be
a beaver pond and one of the interesting
things to think about is that you know
Bieber have this huge impact on the
ecology of our landscape and there were
a lot of beaver like in the 1500s and
this is what this is is an estimate of
the amount of pond surface area in
Columbia County versus year and what you
see is that there was probably a huge
drop-off in the amount of pawn because
the beaver were all trapped out prefer
around 1607
then you started to get mill ponds and
now just now with all this I know if you
have it here or not you have a sort of
fashion for ponds in this area and new
houses yeah okay so that's that's sort
of what what this accounts for but the
thing is they're not the same
ecologically and so we did some work
with with ponds both on farms and off
pond's off pond's off farms so what this
is an index we looked at plants we
looked at various animals so this is
just an index of overall diversity this
is the surrounding land use agricultural
residential mixed or neither and this
was about 95 ponds that we looked at and
what you see is that the agricultural
ponds actually were more diverse than
the residential ponds which you might if
you think about the typical residential
pond you know you might understand this
because most of them are many of them
are mowed around people want to keep
them crystal clear and that's not what
life wants to do and some of these now
these aren't loafing ponds in the middle
of a farmyard but these are might be
pawns and grazed areas these are much
more loosely managed and so they're more
tippers makes sense another analogy
might be vernal pools and we actually do
find some of these vernal pool
amphibians in those farm ponds that
don't have a lot of fish in them wet
meadows again are quite diverse areas
have quite a few native species a place
that probably again probably a lot of
native species relatively speaking
because they were part of the natural
landscape and these are just some pretty
flowers these are wet meadow flowers
some of our this is a beautiful flower
if you know this Cardinal flower
and sorry gotta gotta bring in some
butterflies one of my favorite
butterflies a bronze copper and
Baltimore checker spot with its food
plant turtle head okay what does nature
provide to farming I think there's some
of you who know much more about this
than I do but we have started to try to
look at it in part because as we were
working with farmers you know that's
that's a very much a question that's
important to them yes they're interested
in ecology but of course what can it do
for them and production wise and it's
not an either/or but it's how do you
also respect their perspective and help
them try to understand this aspect
anybody have questions about that part
that I just went through some of you
actually still awake so that's good um
okay ecological services so I sort of
laugh I always feel a little bit
hesitant saying services because it's
kind of like saying that my wife gives
me marital services or something like
that which I or that I give her husband
services in the sense that I think
there's a you know there's more to it
than just the just the nitty-gritty of
the the monetary effects but it's one
way of looking at it and of course bees
are one of the very often talked about
providers of some of these ecological
services this was some work we did
actually a student working with us very
basic stuff you know what are the
different kinds of insects that come and
fertilize on some of the crop plants
well oh yes honey bee but maybe it's
only about a quarter and these other
ones many of these are native species
that are providing those pollination
services and this was again that that
generality this was looking at different
crops and presented a number of native
bee visits for some crops like cucumbers
mainly honeybees for pollinating those
but then for some other ones like the
wild the wild flowers would make sense
but maybe like broccoli raab or up here
the raspberries they were getting more
pollinated by the wild bees
and this builds into our consideration
of landscape because of something like
this now this is not our work this is
from Rufus Isaacs at Michigan State
University looking at bees that
pollinate blueberries but basically this
is the blueberry flowering period and
these are the flight periods of the
different pollinators and so the
question that this poses is okay great
you provide them with a blueberry crop
but how are they staying alive the rest
of the year you know you got to provide
something for them out here if you want
to have those native species around
pollinating your crops right makes sense
so we did a little bit related to that
we going back to that floodplain study i
showed you have any of you been in a
floodplain early in the spring say in
May what do you see wildflowers yeah you
know like bloodroot have you seen
bloodroot what's some other trout Lily
yeah definitely trout Lily blue cohosh
maybe something so it's before the trees
leaf out you have this big burst of
flowers so it's a great place for bees
and what we looked at was the bees on a
farm and an adjacent floodplain and what
we found was that you know about a
quarter of those species here were ones
we found in the spring on the floodplain
and then later in the year in the farm
fields so it just starts to give you
this picture of how the landscape is
supporting what's happening in those
crop fields some of those services this
is just you know another way of looking
at somebody's dude the amount of flowers
around a vegetable garden and the amount
of bees we see and not surprisingly more
flowers more bees except I didn't show
you this one this is the one that screws
up the statistics this observation up
here but what was interesting was when
we went back and looked at that that was
the farm these are 19 different farms in
the county this farm was the San deist
farm so how does that explain the result
ground nesting bees yeah so you have
bees really like to be able to some of
these individual bees nest
in sandy area so when you have sandy
soil it's just a much better habitat for
them so it adds yes flowers and food
sources are important but as every was
is well-recognized nesting sources are
too we've looked at spiders these are
just how many of you have you ever seen
jumping spiders they're really they're
fun spiders because there are the
spiders that look at you so you hold
them in your head and they follow you
around so they're really there is an orb
weaver you probably know these ones too
big our guy appears that you see in them
and a crab spider waiting for somebody
some unfortunate I didn't look up there
forgot the family this might be an am
Aruba but anyway we did a study this
this is our tropical fish slide which
has no no this is the this is actually
an aerial view of Hawthorne Valley Farm
main gardens and so this is where the
crops are this is a little bit of a
historical picture now because they've
changed the arrangement of the farm and
not so much of this is in crop but this
is crop and then these are surrounding
this is pastor this is a riparian area
this is these are wetlands here and what
we did was we just followed the insects
both in the center Pete part of the farm
and also in the surroundings or insects
and spiders a little bit this was an
initial work just to try to understand
how does that change what is the flow of
these invertebrates over the year and
the example here i'm going to show you
with spiders the white area is we just
didn't we couldn't study all of these we
didn't have the person power but the
darker the green the more abundant were
the spiders and so we're just going to
go through the year this is May that's
July June July july-september and then
september-october and the pattern I
think which is sort of summarized here
is that early in the year sort of the
wilder areas and the drive strips which
are the uncultivated areas they tended
to have the most spiders whereas by the
end of the year the crops and the crop
edges have the most spiders so you can
picture we have to know this better and
this is a little bit just adjust
Oh story but you can picture there's a
flow going on here perhaps the the
spiders earlier in the year coming into
these or central crop areas you know
wasps or another important provider this
is the this is the tomato hornworm well
well parasitized do you know what with
the wasps due to tomato hornworm have
you seen that so they they're actually a
control of the tomato hornworm but not
this wasp in particular but another much
smaller wasp and this was just you know
the relationship between the amount of
forest at each of these 19 different
farms and the amount of in this case
wingless wasps that we found in our
trapping and there is a significant
relationship the more the forest you
have the more of these wingless wasps
you have again very gross information
you'd have to look at more detail but
suggestive of a relationship between the
landscape and the amount of these
beneficials this is my other family I
this is I what I have a chance to work
with insects this is what I work with a
lot the ground beetles the crabbits an
interesting group some of which are I
have to confess summer pests but many of
them hopefully the majority of them are
actually beneficial there we they can be
both pest predators and weed seed
predators and we just start to look at
the patterns how do these how are these
communities of beetles distributed on
the landscape this was a study we did we
basically we looked at the beetles that
we found in the crops in this case we
were just looking at tomato in the
surrounding grassy areas and then then
in the forest and just ask the question
how these communities related you know
is this if you look at veggies grassland
and woods is it all essentially one
beetle community or is it something like
this where they're each completely
distinct beetle communities and of
course as most ecological answers are
the answers sort of or kind of or
somewhat but basically we ended up with
with data like this these are different
ground beetle species you know the
amount the percentage of captures and
the cultivated the edge areas in the
wilder section some of them are
basically only in the cultivated areas
but some of them spread out more widely
and to you know go further with this
you'd have to understand which of these
are really most important in terms of
those agro ecological services but again
it's just trying to look at the the
patterns of life on the landscape
relative to the services they might
provide ok so far we want it to ask ok
which if we look at these three areas we
look at the veggies we look at the woods
we look at the surrounding grassland
what are the what are the ones that are
most related to each other and we just
looked at correlations you know how how
closely correlated as the abundance of
ants spiders and ground beetles in
veggies versus ants spiders and ground
beetles in woodlands you know what's and
basically which this so is the higher
the value the more closely correlated
that the two communities were so grass
and wood yeah you know more than a third
of the cases were significantly
correlated more than a third of the
different insect groups who looked at
whereas woods and veggies were not so
closely correlated and so
diagrammatically the that's represented
by woods and grassland quite similar in
community or relatively grassland and
veggie and somewhat vegging woodland not
quite so much you don't need to see that
it was fine this I just put up there in
case our technician came we're also
looking at ads and Kyle the technische I
show you implicate ants and this is the
same sort of thing but for different ad
species if you're into ants I can show
you that slide in more detail later we'd
love to understand this is some of the
work that Emily did but not this in
particular but this whole theme of soils
again how has the landscape changed how
has soil life changed and how does that
affect what can happen today on the
landscape this is some historical data
on organic matter in cropland hey pastor
and forest in New York State I couldn't
find something specifically for our
County this is from our county it may or
may not be a completely valid comparison
but the forest value is you know around
seven but what's interesting is you know
the amount
organic matter here persons apparently
how much is decreased over that time
what effect has that had on soil life
you know this is this is the answer I
don't know what the answer is this was
one of our attempt to look at it and
it's just like all over the board I
won't even try to explain that Emily did
some work on the Hawthorne Valley Farm
where she looked at fields that had been
in hanging pasture and veggies over
quite a few at least 10 years we had
actually individual data on how much was
coming in and out of those fields what
effect did that have on the soils we did
grow outs you can talk to Emily about
that it was a somewhat was a somewhat
messy picture although interestingly
when you grew soils when you grew plants
in these soils it seems like the actual
the height of the plant did correspond
to what you predict very roughly from
our budgets of nutrients in and out
emily is nodding reassuringly that I'm
not talking complete nonsense when I'm
up here another thing to look at
ecological services that people don't
always think about is you know these are
some of the pastures at haathon Valley
and if you're a grazier you look at this
and say oh my god you know they're
grazing on that these things these
aren't sheep their cows but one thing
that people have started to look at is
actually the role of else let me just go
back I'll just use this the role of
fields like this in self-medication so
actually cows have been shown to
self-medicate to a certain degree and
that means they go out and they find
different plants in their landscape that
might help them if they've got a high
parasite load what is this important
does it have a milk effect we don't know
yet but that might be another sort of a
service that the Botanical diversity is
providing 22 cal health I'll go over
that I want to get the butterflies again
just a thought you know there's
obviously how these different habitats
are arranged around the farm but there's
also what you do on the farm this is a
wildflower strip and this farm happened
to be surrounded by wetland so we got
this amazing diversity of what actually
fairly rare wetland butterflies coming
in and neck during here and this was a
nice combination of how this farm was
actually inter
with its landscape okay going on to a
little bit other aspects of our program
you know we do work with farmers but we
work a lot with the general public and
you've got a picture columbia county is
two hours in north of New York City and
that means you know we have a lot of
second homes in some towns more than a
third of the homes or second homes what
is it here does anybody know what
proportion of homes our second homes
anybody got an idea I don't know but
anyway by the third or second homes we
have people coming up on weekends things
like that and so you have people coming
in they're often coming in with ideas
about how they want to manage the
landscape and part of our program is how
do you sort of help them you know slow
down and look at where they are without
telling them this is bad this is good
but just how do you help them realize a
bit better where they are in the
landscape and this is a little picture I
put together a long time ago but I still
like it and it actually came out of
talking to somebody who was a postdoc
over natural resources who was a
designer of parks and he said look if
you're going to have a park and you want
people to come you design it so that the
greatest diversity of people come to
that you might have art you might have
history you might have ecology and so
this is what I call a park of local
knowledge and caring and of course it
doesn't exist as a physical part but the
idea is if you want people to connect to
their landscape how can you bring them
into it well some people get connected
with food some love history some love
nature Appreciation some want to go
through formal schooling like some love
technology so maybe you have to do a
Facebook page but the idea is as we try
to connect people to the landscape how
can we diversify these different ways
that they can enter that landscape and
you know this is one this was our
attempt at ecotourism join the crazy
connection this was a really one that
took a bit of explaining to farmers this
was our pond study you know so why
exactly do you want to go out in the
middle of my mucky Cal pond with a canoe
we were doing sediment cores but anyway
we've had nobody take us up on this
offer you
we try to look at you know communicate
the idea of history because people like
to be part of a story this was a one
thing that really hit us that we hadn't
been expecting we went and we gave the
psychological talk we gave this a little
bit at the beginning about history we've
ever got done with the talking nobody
asked ecological questions they were all
fascinated with the history part and so
what we want to try to do is we don't
want to forget about the ecological part
that help people understand where they
are you're here you know you can sort of
say a big sign you're here this is where
history is at now history is going to
keep running what's happened in the past
and how does that affect where we may be
going this is actually happens to be
different animals in Columbia County
this was the sheep boom if any of you
have looked at agricultural history it
was a big and there's some you know
really high class espionage associated
with that there was actually the merino
sheep the Spanish sheep who are very
important very valued part of the
European wool production and there were
these all these covert actions to to get
sheep out of Europe this hat then this
is your goal you want to have one of
these in here so anyway this is just
agricultural history in Columbia County
over the years the different types of
production and I if anybody's interested
in attic history I can go into it but
I'm just trying to give you the feel for
what we communicate to people to help
them feel like they're part of something
but we also want to help them you know
yes we're interested in ecology yes
we're interested in agriculture but how
might that translate into the
communities that they're living in even
if they're not farmers and so this is
the percentage of the Columbia County
Workforce in agriculture service and
retail and manufacturing over about 200
years so it gives people you know we're
here right now we've got a huge service
retail component very little in
agriculture very little in manufacturing
not saying you want to go back here but
it shows you what has happened on the
land and what might conceivably be
possible and we do want to talk about
land cover this is the amount of forest
over time the amount of farmland the
amount of shrubland again just trying to
say okay here's the history and then how
does that translate into the ecology
and we work in terms of how we get out
and work with people these are just some
of the ways some of the people we've
worked with we have interns we've got
people who are part of a natural history
participatory research group this is a
rice farmer from up in Vermont who just
really loves dragonflies it comes down
and spends a couple days with us each
year so just how we reach out to people
we work with some of the regional
conservation organizations many of whom
have farmland and so we help them with
management plans this is a really neat
if any of you are into shakers it's a
really fascinating story of ecology and
culture in Lebanon which I could go into
more of people are interested and we
appear at various events and we do
nature walks and we want to make sure we
did do some work with students so we get
them out there on the coldest rainiest
days and really what it makes you feel
is it makes you feel old so you know
there I am out there bundled up and
there was somebody in a t-shirt and
shorts a teenager obviously there's some
metabolic change has happened here that
but anyway and we try to go try to go
online this is our blog it's our
Facebook page this is our soon-to-be
launched redesigned web page but the
point is that trying to think of again
it's that Park idea you know I'm not
into facebook i never did facebook until
i had that thing that but people told us
you know a lot of the lot of younger
people do have Facebook pages that's a
group of people we haven't connected
with well so we have a Facebook page
it's fun I mean I do enjoy it this is
one of our main projects right now the
living land project the goal of this is
we're putting together a field guide to
the culture and ecology of our landscape
so we've been doing this happens to be
Columbia County where you see it this is
the outline we divvied it up into
different ecological regions and then
we're trying to look at the habitats in
each of these regions and we're going to
try to put it together field guide so if
you're a landowner you can go out and
say okay what's sort of forest do I have
in my backyard at the same time we also
want to look at the ecological chiral
aspect so the question becomes okay you
have this kind of forest in your
backyard how do your neighbors perceive
that forest
how might a farmer think of that forest
and we're not trying to say you know
that's the right perception that's the
wrong perception it's not that it's just
how does how do the people around you
perceive of that landscape and can we
use this approach to help people
understand you know not only where they
are culturally but also ecologically and
you get to have pretty got another
butterfly this is a big spring
salamander a beautiful orange bright
salamander like that at my and we hadn't
found in the county my son said what's
this that's what it was finding more
orchids around and you know these sort
of pictures are important because again
who are we communicating with we're
communicating with people who are going
to rely congrat for example we want to
have the graphs to back up our ideas but
this is how we're going to reach
people's their heart and then just a
little bit about what Anna's work has
been some of it already has to do with
connecting people to the landscape but
anna has done a lot of fun work looking
at the food system in the county and
again I'm not going to go into this in
detail but i can give you links it's on
our website i can connect you with anna
she did a whole project on the columbia
county food system because farmers were
farmers that asked us know what how does
this work economically and so she did
again you're not expected to read the
small print unless you want to come up
and try to read it but you know CSAs how
do they relate to the different we have
csas in the city we have csa is up in
the county how do the perceptions that
people have and what they want to get
out of it differ based on where they're
from farmers market what is it what are
the prices what do people want to get
from their farmers market anyway that
kind of a study that helps us understand
how people are using a landscape this
was a fun project she did on new farmers
I imagine it's the same here you
probably got quite a few new farmers new
farms coming up is that am i right and
in Columbia County that's also the case
and so she she interviewed many of these
farmers put together profiles of each of
the different farm
and put together this is a map of again
Columbia County going to get familiar
with this shape and these are the
different new farms there and partially
again it gets it gives us an idea of how
people are are using the ecology of
people on this landscape I guess you
could say and she also asked some more
specific questions about their
relationships to the land so as we try
to communicate some of those like
ecological maps I was showing you
earlier well yeah we can stand up here
and tell it well or share what we feel
is important but we also need to
understand what the people what they
feel is important so try to understand
their perspectives on the landscape can
help us share ours more and also help us
design our research so it's most useful
for them and this is the part of the
living land project it's what we call a
special places display and it's
basically this is there it is again
lumbia County it's a big board where you
get to come up to it like it if you're
at a farmers market you come up to it
and if you want to you can put where
your special places on this map and you
know where do you go to hunt where do
you go to look for nice views where do
you go when you want to go swimming or
whatever that of course some of this in
secret and people don't want to share
but the idea is you come out with a map
like this that starts to show you sort
of the tapada the cultural topography of
your landscape what are the places that
are really neat to people and how again
do you build that interest into helping
them connect with their landscape may be
spreading that interest out but also
honoring the places that they want to
visit or feel that are important so what
do we learnt this is the hardest slide
to make it's probably the most boring
one to look at too but basically these
are just some sort of the generalities
that I would say we've been at this for
about 10 years you know ecologically I
think it still continues to surprise me
how much land use history has an effect
on what we're seeing today it's not
that's not something new but again it's
just what personally we learned and then
the fine-scale patterns of the unseen
world there's just to go on to the some
force and go like Kyle who's the ant a
biologist so he's found an ant that's
common in Columbia County and the only
other place that's known as Iowa Ohio
so why why is it not known from New
England I have no idea we have no idea
but it's these sort of mysteries and
patterns you know there's a lot going
out there and they're responding two
aspects the habitat but we don't see or
understand a Glee ecology so I I mean I
do believe that agriculture has the
potential not saying it's automatic to
create important natural concert nature
conservation benefits through those
analogies we talked about the AB and
flow of farm relevant life in the
importance of understanding community
set so this is the this is those those
agricultural services that I'm talking
about and understanding where are these
creatures coming from what's affecting
how far they travel what's affecting the
habitats they need for overwintering or
what have you sir those commuting
strategies relative to the aggregate
collage achill services and then you
know can we associate biodiversity
actually with benefits in production and
that's a big if but but it's sort of the
core of really making this relevant for
the farmers sociologically you know one
of the fun things I had not worked with
farmers before going on in interacting
with farmers a lot of them are really
just key if you didn't come in in a
situation where you know you're doing
this wrong this this Creek is all dirty
you shouldn't be doing this but more let
me just show you what's in your creek
great you know I my kids play in the
creek I sometimes wade in the creek I'd
love to know more about the nature and
so a lot of the farmers were really
interested in that although you might
not have the time to do much about it
people like to be part of a story I
talked about that um it's hard to find a
substitute for person to for into
individual interactions you know you can
put together and this is what funding
agencies want you to do they want you to
put together pamphlets to give to
farmers to tell them what to do there's
value in that but working interacting
with the farmers individually much
smaller group of people but I think you
have a much bigger potentially much
bigger impact the range of ecological
knowledge among people is alarming and
awe-inspiring so it's just it's been
really fun where you find people that
know you wouldn't expect it in they go
oh yeah
I know that yeah I know what this is and
then other places where you go I have no
idea wait wait you don't have any idea
so it's it's it's all the way that that
sort of a realization is always
interesting and ecological humility is a
learned trait and this is one of the
things as people come up and want to do
landscaping you know they have this
vision of what they want to do with
their land and trying to convince them
to take a year or two to understand
where the land is add is some time to
have that humility is sometimes
difficult and again this is just deserve
a summary of how we view what we do you
know we want to build compassion and
stewardship for the land well that's
going to come if people love the land
and if you love something you have
curiosity about it the curiosity you ask
questions with leads to research and you
build knowledge and the more you know
about something potentially the more you
love it so this is kind of how we view
what we do as a program and the last
very very last proposed study and this
is short so don't worry almost time
you're still following me way
this is these are maps that we did not
do but this is scenic Hudson recently
came out this relates to this study were
thinking about recently came out with it
they call foodshed conservation studies
so that what they looked at is the the
farms that sell in new york city where
are they located and in the Hudson
Valley this is where those farms are
located and so they prioritized areas
based on where those farms are in terms
of conservation and the question is okay
let's go the next step this is
production conservation this is not
nature conservation so how do you take a
map like that and then start to
translate it into okay how can that
farmland production conservation also
have an important nature conservation
component so what role can Hudson Valley
farming play in regional nature
conservation given the diversity of
landscapes in the valley how can farming
best support native species what are the
sub-region specific target ecological
analogies in other words you know this
is up in here for example we have a lot
of fence Ozar the calcareous wetlands
farms play a role in preserving fens but
that may be irrelevant over here there
may be some other habitats that farms
are playing a more important role in so
trying to understand the distribution of
those target conservation communities is
one aspect of what we want to try to do
what role can nature play in supporting
hudsonville and fart valley farming okay
so that's going into what that other
part of the talk I had know what are the
cert how can these natural areas also
help provide services to the farms
themselves you know a big and there's
technical questions in there how do we
how do we measure those services in a
relevant way and I you know I don't know
the answer this is part of what we're
trying to work on and it's in
collaboration with some people here and
some people at scenic Hudson and some
other places so that
is the end
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu